et bien bonjour à vous bonjour à toi
clément qui montre cette vidéo j'espère
que tout le monde va bien
aujourd'hui je suis très content parce
que je fais une vidéo où j'ai parlé
d'une nouvelle passion que j'ai
découvert le savez je me découvre des
passions tous les mois mais y'a plein de
trucs qui me fascine c'est coûteux fait
ce n'est pas plein de choses hélas ce
qui me fascine c'est les vidéos de l'ina
vous connaissez sûrement il y en a
certaines qui ont tourné sur facebook
énormément qu'est-ce que les nas et
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel qui
est chargée entre d'archivés les
émissions radios les émissions télé et
c'est incroyable je sais pas il ya
peut-être que moi qui est ce qu'ils font
mais je trouve ça fou de voir des gens
qui ont notre âge mais 50 ans ou 60 ans
avant nous c'est impressionnant la vidéo
la plus connue li na c'est une série
d'interviews auprès des jeunes où on
leur demandait en 62 comment selon eux
allaient être l'an 2000
je vous ai dit en descriptions se
voulait aller la voir mais elle a
tellement tourné sur facebook que moi
papa fait que ça ensemble
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a vraiment
juste regarder les trucs par exemple qui
concerne ce n'est pas à l'école la
technologie comment penser les jeunes
comment penser nos parents quand ils
avaient notre âge on sait les parents on
sait comment vous pensiez pascal
épreuves sur l'ina vous n'avez pas pensé
à supprimer ces archives
regardons ces ensembles j'ai fait une
petite sélection qui parle de type est
un truc je sais pas trop si elles ont
trouvé sur facebook celle ci mais en
tout cas j'ai envie de vous en parler
parce qu à pas mal de choses à dire
alors c'est parti je vous contextualise
on est en 65 et un journaliste a
interviewé deux jeunes pour leur
demander ce qu'ils pensent de la france
comment ils sont d'avis qu'ils sont bien
ce qu'ils sont malheureux qu est-ce qui
va pas dans le pays etc
et c'est incroyable alors attention ces
deux jeunes ne représente pas tous les
jeunes de l'époque mais leur témoignage
est incroyable on vous sort toujours la
même formule les français nous avons
sens du ridicule c'est absolument
stupide alors ça englobe des tas de
convention qui sont absolument
inconfortable on peut pas vivre quoi
sais pas je ne sais pas de quoi il parle
pour l'ouvragé de comment va pour leur
style s'il vous plaît je veux que ceux
ci reviennent à la mode s'il vous plaît
moi c'est trop tard pour moi monsieur
condé veut cela à les y laisser vous
poussez les voeux sam croyable france le
spécial
des tas de choses qui
je trouve les gens cons
moi évoluer en angleterre
leur esprit critique tout mais tu
critique aussi la actuellement était en
train de chier sur tout le monde c'est
génial il se plaint que les gens
critiquent tout mais il lui même la est
en train de tout critiquer partir du
moment où on a les cheveux longs et
raides les gens comprennent pas pour ils
sont bêtes ils sont bons non le pauvre
le pauvre tout s'explique il en a marre
du monde parce que tout le monde se
moque de sa chevelure mais rassure-toi
45 ans plus tard ta coupe est devenu
archi à la morgue regardes tu étais
juste visionnaire et comme tous les
visionnaires et genton critiquée bien
joué à toi non non absolument pas et si
vous êtes des hippies vous êtes des quoi
j'arrive pas comment ce qu'il dit vous
êtes des beatniks peu dépité je sais pas
ce que c'est mais j'y parle d'un
mouvement anti confort et c'est un plan
de systèmes et j'arrive pas à trouver le
nom clémence et à lyon marque le là moi
je les pages est pas la culture qu'il
faut c'est horrible absolument pas alors
là moi j'aime le contraire quand je pars
en vacances il me faut une villa excuse
nous pardo monsieur il lui faut sa villa
sinon il ne part pas en vacances hors de
question je n'aime pas aller à la plage
avec tout le monde m'a absolument mon
confort avant tout j'ai jamais vu avait
dire je pense à ma gueule et uniquement
à ma gueule aussi librement ils
s'embêtent cool je vais pas vivre en
france j'aime pas les français j'aime
pas là la réaction des français jeu
qu'est ce que vous leur reprochez je
leur reproche tout reminder reminder je
trouve les gens
par leur esprit critique tout se
révolter ces jeunes d'importants
d'argent pour vous bien sûr ces
n'apportant rien à [ __ ] moi je veux
sans argent je m'emmerde je suis parent
bien je ne suis pas heureux il faut mon
petit bain chaud il faut même âme et mon
petit steak tous les midis moi j'aime ça
et donner la médaille de l'honnêteté acv
j'aime l'argent je veux mon steak ma
villa près de la plage je m'en bats les
couilles à cette franchise ça c'est un
truc à changer cette franchise là elle
est incroyable le travail ça vous ennuie
qu'on travaille je travaille et c'est à
dire de moi que je veux faire ce pas
exactement du travail c'est ce qu'il
vous plaît vous avez c'est intéressant
pour lui la notion de travail c'est
quelque chose qui ne plaît pas même
encore aujourd'hui encore plus cette
vision genre le travail c'est forcément
quelque chose qui ne plaît pas mais on
peut avoir un travail qui nous qui nous
plaît à l'époque je me sens que c'était
vraiment beaucoup plus inconcevable quoi
de faire de son de sa passion son
travail et c'est hyper intéressant je
trouve qu'ils aient ces deux jeunes qui
bossent et où il y en a ils parlent même
de faire sciences po grandes écoles et
houleux mais ils sont très fait que le
système est cette même personne là qui à
l'époque chier sur le système et le
monde aujourd'hui cinquante ans après te
dis à moi de mon époque on sortait les
doigts du cul 1 on n'était pas comme ça
on accepter les choses comme elles
étaient et ben non on voit bien que
c'est faux
si ton papa te dis qu'à son époque lui
l'était pas comme toi y accepter son
destin est tout de même contre lui ça et
si c'est ton père dans la vidéo c'est
encore mieux
bon autre sujet intéressant c'est
l'école dans l'émission qui suit on
passe en 84 et ils vont aller
interviewer des élèves et le sujet est
centrée sur la triche de quoi découvrir
à l'époque comment les gens trichent et
ne trichait pas encore c'est pas du tout
le message que je véhicule et une
nouvelle manière de fraude est inventée
par un candidat au baccalauréat d'orly
non pas question pour lui d'employer les
vieux trucs du genre antisèches
dissimulé sur les poignées de chemise ou
encore formule inscrite dans le creux de
la main comment at il fait les années 80
qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est autant pas
si vite possible
ok pas si le mec il a un truc de la
taille d'un s'est tapé dans l'oreille
mon gars d'où il espérait ne pas se
faire griller le gars il est comme ça et
en plus il fait ça ok attends attends
pas si vite la production agricole 10
mois combien combien excusez moi mais
j'ai ferdinand vous trichez non pas du
tout je réfléchis simplement à haute
voix bon d'accord alors mais enfin
évidemment mais tu te fais griller
on attend avec les téléphones portables
et tout ça ça peut peut-être moins vous
étonner mais à l'époque c'était fou
qu'un candidat ait triché en utilisant
une sorte de radio genre le petit malin
était ainsi beast fervent il disposait
d'un émetteur récepteur à peu près gros
comme ceux ci de deux petits écouteurs
dissimulé dans une chevelure évidemment
beaucoup plus abondante que la mienne à
6 à la chevelure abondante la chevelure
abondante la sauver sa petite amie
complaisante disposer de tous les
ouvrages nécessaires complet ça va faire
face à n'importe quelle épreuve
d'histoire géo du ballon mais la triche
était presque parfaite
presque seulement pourquoi il s'est fait
griller qu'est ce qui se passait
n'importe quel cibis de passage dans les
environs vous pouvez entendre plus aussi
le dialogue et c'est ce qui s'est
produit
la suite fondé à 86 et l'émission parle
toujours de la proche du baccalauréat et
donc de la triche anneron gère ce livre
un exercice que la morale réprouve
elle va nous dévoiler quelques recettes
de triche oui vous avez bien entendu
d'autriche des recettes tirées des
manuels à pertinents rédigé par un jeune
nantais qui n'a pas froid aux yeux et un
mec de nantes qu'à rédiger un manuel
avec plein de méthodes de triche mais
cet effort dans ses révisions mais pas
dans le but de corrompre les gens
désirent et audric 20 ans c'est parce
qu'ils voulaient consacrer plus de temps
au tennis qu'il a mis au point sa
méthode en vain le son pour tricher aux
examens déjà on dirait qu'il a 30 ans il
ya peut-être une raison au fait que y
passe son temps à tricher avec ses
petits camarades de classe il a
sélectionné pour nous ces quelques
conseils que la morale réprouve
des lots désir audric le reste se passe
de commentaires ahahah le style en farsi
les new kids hommes aux techniques de
triche elles sont incroyables oui ok
jusque là tout le monde connaît tout ça
le sac à malices vous dira d'objets de
harry potter c'est quoi le sac à malices
ah d'accord tu sors juste et cours quoi
et tu les cages dans ta copie dans mes
mecs ta copie elle passe de sa
d'épaisseur à ça ne me dites pas que
c'est pas griller ok là il ya désir
audric notre dieu à tous qui nous
dévoile une technique et regardez juste
son investissement personnel dans
l'élaboration de techniques de triche
c'est incroyable vous prenez une grotte
dans laquelle vous accrocher un
élastique l'intermédiaire d'une épingle
à nourrice longs cils et le long du mât
jusqu'en haut de l'épaule
en vrai désir audric il aurait dû juste
finir ingénieurs et ça a mal tourné et
il est devenu ingénieur dans
l'élaboration techniques de triche ça
c'est vraiment ça s'est joué à ça et
maintenant l'interview légendaire de
daisy rodrigues ses arguments saut je
triche cours en fait parce que j'aime
bien faire autre chose que travailler
mes examens quand je vois arriver les
sujets couverts l'argument pas bah on a
montré les sujets complètement stupide
où il suffit juste de recracher le court
à ce moment-là bon bah qu'est ce que je
fais moi je veux pas passer cinq ou six
heures à travailler ça ce que je fais
c'est que j'ai des cours que j'amène
directement alors que la personne qui a
qui a travaillé pour préparer l'examen
intellectuellement on retire absolument
rien à cette phrase rageux jeudi je dise
exactement paris parce que génèrera jeu
comme lui et moi je vais pas à l'école
pour apprendre bêtement un truc parker
et la réussite et sur une copie oui mais
lui casser ça l'école c'est la même
chose pour tout le monde si d'autres
sont capables
tu peux en être aussi en fait il n'ya
pas de nom non non non non je vais
plutôt m'investir dans la triche
j'ai de l'avenir qu'est-ce que vous
conseilleriez un jeune qui débute bah
non c'est ce que tu as dit rodrigue de
travail et de pas tout de suite tombé
dans la triche était bienveillant on
sait bien funky les buts conseillant
kate moss et pourquoi mais non en fait
c'est un gars ils n'ont ju concert est
de démarrer avec des méthodes très
simple et très sûr ok audric et rob sic
au pape
avez vous déjà vu quelqu'un ferrari si
sincère pour redevenir sérieux en moins
d'une demi seconde
j'ai tellement cru qu'il était sérieux
la première fois que j'ai vu quand il a
dit non non c'est un gars qui s'amassent
mis sur le cul va peut-être que vous
venez de vivre ça vous chez vous c'est
traumatisant n'est ce pas j'ai avec une
bonne partie des gens qui
ont travaillé durant leur scolarité
parce qu'il n'arrivait pas à pompe et
généralement quand on travaille c'est
qu'on sait pas pompé ce n'est pas du
tout parce que peut-être qu'on a envie
de travailler et d'accepter le système
est de se dire c'est pas mal en fait
j'apprends des trucs ça ma culture
générale lll au gré des tout c'est cool
non
si vous travaillez c'est que vous ne
savez pas trompé ces hold up qui l'a dit
bon voilà cela est fait rire de brassage
de voir quelle époque déjà la triche
c'était très d'actualité avec les gens
ils mettaient tout leur coeur c'est fou
après la triche parlant d'un truc un peu
plus cool l'arrivée des inventions
technologiques quand les médias
commencent à apparaître une technologie
qui faisait un peu entendu parler d'elle
on savait pas trop ce que ça allait
donner on savait pas trop si ça allait
impacté le monde ou pas et salah impacté
et du coup quand on les revoit présenter
ça à l'époque sans savoir ce qui va se
passer derrière c'est très intéressant
commence tout de suite avec les médias
qui parlent des jeux vidéo nouveau venu
cette année qui marche très fort le jeu
vidéo ppda cfoot a présenté le jeu vidéo
comme un nouveau venu ça me paraît
tellement incroyable comme tout est allé
si vite petit frère du flipper et autres
machines à sous qui ne se rencontrent a
guère que dans les cafés les jeux vidéo
font leur entrée dans les salles de
séjour
dias grâce à lui j'ai fait de ma passion
mon métier dans quelques années x 200 le
tour on jouait contre la machine et nous
pourrons utiliser la main le petit
ordinateur de ménage pour faire sa
comptabilité personnelle
on va organiser ses vacances voir tout
faire assez fou s'il savait c'est dingue
il parle juste de faire sa petite
comptabilité mais mec marrant on fait
tout avec notre pc on organise tout neuf
journées on parle avec les hôtes ont ça
fait tellement tout ça fait tellement
plus que ce qu'ils imaginaient que ça
ferait à ce moment là c'est axe trouve
incroyable enfin dernière innovation
dont ils vont parler c'est l'arrivée du
gros comme anne les premiers baladeurs
portables pour écouter ta musique dans
la rue etc et vous allez voir c'était
vraiment une énorme nouveauté c'est
vraiment un bouleversement quand c'est
arrivé pour nous ça me paraît normal
maintenant tourner à des écouteurs dans
le métro dans la rue tout on écoute la
musique quand il veut mais à l'époque
personne faisait ça aide un coup des
gens se sont mis à avoir des casques sur
les oreilles à faire ça et c'était assez
ma vie vous allez voir comme il est
présente c'est intéressant depuis 18
mois environ au wat en france des hommes
et des dames aussi bien qu'ils ont sur
les oreilles un casque leur permettant
d'écouter la musique même dans les
bruits de la circulation ce sont des
walkman vous avez sûrement croisé au
détour d'une rue
un de ses personnages bizarres coiffé
d'un drôle de casse un de ses
personnages bizarres
il ne manquait que les antennes pour
évoquer une autre planète ouais cette
phrase elle montre bien qu'elle pourrait
c'était incroyable de voir des gens avec
des casse les oreilles c'était j'en veux
des gens venus d'un autre monde presque
c'était n'importe quand on n'avait
jamais vu ça avant mais beaucoup de gens
qui me regardent avec un scanner une
nouvelle génération du 20e siècle
ça les étonne un peu de voir le walkman
mais moi je m'en fous éperdument du mont
houy je suis bien c'est principale entre
pâques et un peu la même chose
aujourd'hui avec tous les jeunes cons et
téléphone dans les marais les gens un
peu plus âgé d'une autre génération vont
dire c'est quoi ça et sont bizarres ces
gens ils sont tout le temps sur leur
écran comme ça et va ces gens là qui ont
acheté un walkman quand ils étaient
jeunes leurs parents avaient le même
discours avec eux et nous on fera bien
entendu pareil avec nos enfants qu'ils
utiliseront une nouvelle technologie
qu'on comprend pas trop ces choses à fou
comme on reproduit tout le temps une
invention qui enchante surtout les
vendeurs 1 millions d'appareils vendus
en france depuis un an et demi
son prix entre 800 et 1200 francs [ __ ]
entre 100 et 200 euros quand même
c'était cher une mode
oui mais une mode peut être pas sans
conséquences il ne s'agit pas d' éviter
aux autres le bruit que l'on peut faire
mais de s'éviter à soit le bruit et la
présence des autres et 6 passes a
on les psychiatres
c'est une nouvelle rupture plus grave
que celle des générations alors ce
danseur ou walkman
faut-il un pas en arrière ou un pas en
avant l'ifa giga pas en avant je veux le
voir tous les matins sur mon trajet pour
le studio est la dernière que je trouve
incroyable que je vais vous montrer
c'est un truc sur les poissons d'avril à
l'époque en fait la télévision française
et les médias jouer vraiment jeu du
poisson d'avril
il se faisait vraiment chez pour monter
un vrai canular et les gens y croyaient
vraiment pas mal c'est un peu une
tradition les gens généralement été
offusquées devant lequel mineur parce
que le canular c'était souvent une
soi-disante loi qu'elle est passée et
qui allait en gros réduire les libertés
des gens sauf que il ya des cannes et là
qu'ils ont fait à l'époque et ça s'est
vraiment passé aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment dans la loi aujourd'hui et
c'est super drôle de se dire qu'à
l'époque qu'ils ont présenté un truc
comme un canular et qu'aujourd'hui c'est
pas ces moyens de jeunes juste de
répéter ce que j'ai dit mais c'est super
gros noms en 72 le canular c'est
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics ce qui est aujourd'hui en
rigueur mais à l'époque c'est
inimaginable une cigarette
vous ne pourrez plus le fair en toute
liberté dans mon ministre après
consultation naturellement avec le
gouvernement et avec le ministre de
l'environnement a décidé la suppression
de la licence que constituait la
possibilité de fumer dans les lieux
publics
désormais tous les français devront s'y
conformer croyez vous que cette mesure
sera facile à faire appliquer
certainement pas chacun sait que le
français très individualiste qu'il croit
beaucoup à ses droits et peut à ses
doigts mais est ce que notre peuple a
toujours détesté notre peuple c'est fou
aimons nous soyons fiers de nous bon
alors qu'en pensent les gens là on veut
voir les témoignages là ne plus fumer
dans les lieux publics c'est terrible
dit nous parce que qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette interdiction de fumer
dans les lieux publics
oui il dit j'ai appris ça ce matin parce
qu'à l'époque tout mon lisez les
journaux tout le monde d'écouter la
radio n'y avait pas autant de médias que
maintenant du coup vraiment les gens
lisaient le truc et on était au courant
en même temps de l'interdiction donc le
canada il paraissait tellement réel des
atteintes à la liberté individuelle et
la prime en qu'on avait les avis sont
mitigés quand même ça intéressant alors
que caen s'est passé derrière tout le
monde comprenait quoi bon s'est passé
beaucoup plus tard attention en quelle
année 2006 s'est passé quarante ans plus
tard mais alors déjà à l'époque ya plein
de gens qui étaient pour il a fallu
quarante ans pour que ça pour que ça
passe c'est fou ce que ça peut gêner les
légendes
dans la rue dans la rivière lot fuir les
voitures pourquoi
l'argument vu les voitures tout on a le
droit
j'adore pourquoi la minorité fait le
choix de faire quelque chose qui nie que
sa santé et celle de ceux qui n'ont pas
fait ce choix aussi et qui sont en plus
la majorité mais la solution c'est quoi
c'est que la majorité se cassent ils
sont pas contents argument d'enfer il
gagne tout un des canulars et je vous
fous la paix c'est le téléphone dans les
voitures à l'époque n'avait pas de
téléphone portable
enfin il y en avait avec eux c'était un
énorme truc qu'on tenait on tenait le
combiné en fait y avait une antenne et
ça coûtait la peau du cul c'est
inaccessible
hélas le cas du lait a fait croire
qu'enfin il ya un téléphone portable qui
sera dans les voitures et qui sera hyper
accessible ce qui est forcé d un
téléphone dans sa voiture de type
portable comme celui ci est un
investissement coûteux comme et revint à
25000 francs l'appareil presque 4000
euros le téléphone dès le mois de juin
prochain
les japonais vont investir le marché
européen en important des combinés
téléphoniques pour voitures au prix de
900 francs
c'est pour contrer cette invasion que
les télécommunications vont proposer aux
usagers un système imparable à la portée
de toutes les bourses à la montre et le
nul à stephen king dans les voitures à
quoi il ressemble voici l'appareil
proposé par les télécommunications il
ressemble étrangement à un appareil
qu'on branchait soit son prix 250 francs
auquel il est relié à l'auto radio sur
la bande fm
de l'autre côté sur la bande fm mais
c'est la même prise qu'on utilise chez
soi ça soit les mecs qu'ils aient le
canada avec les moyens du bord j'adore
bon comment ça marche dit nous qu'est-ce
que vous avez inventé l'antenne radio
transmet la fréquence jusqu'au relais
hertziens des télécoms de mesnil esnard
lequel renvoie la communication au
central téléphonique qui joue son rôle
normalement
en fait les signalent par à un endroit
puis repart un autre race et
technologique a franchement j'aurais cru
direct à l'époque avoué c'est super bien
fait et bien écoutez c'est la fin de
cette petite revue de vidéos de l'ina
j'ai pas pris les plus connus je peux
vous les aviez pas bu en tout cas pour
ceux qui connaissaient pas ou ce qu'on
avait vu juste deux ou trois je vous
invite à aller sur la chaîne youtube je
mettrais bien une description c'est
vraiment très intéressant et je trouve
que ça fait réaliser plein de choses il
ya vraiment eu des gap technologique
énorme une manière de penser aussi qui a
beaucoup changé mais pas tant on l'a vu
et surtout moi donc
dans ma tête ça c'était vraiment y'a je
sais pas combien de temps je suis pas
qu'on veut dire j'aime tant que c'était
il ya cent ans quoi mais pas du tout en
fait il ya vraiment que 35 ans d'écart
entre certaines vidéos qu'on a vu et
maintenant c'est rien 35 ans c'est juste
que vos parents bas il avait notre âge
au moment où ça s'est sorti quoi je
trouve ça fou comme tout va très vite
comme tout a changé très très vite quoi
le regarder maintenant il ya des ipad
des téléphones portables des écrans 4
cas des jeux vidéo incroyable en 3d qui
tourne et regardez il ya seulement 35
ans on était si loin de ça c'est fou je
vous dis à bientôt à une prochaine vidéo
je m'en vais poser plein de questions à
mes parents parce que ça me fascine en
ce moment leur époque et je vous dis à
bientôt
voilà portez vous bien au revoir
[Musique]
un pas
ouais
[Musique]